[音楽]
[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは今度はけらです
私は医師になって40年余り
毎日の内科診療を楽しんでまいりました
何故かと申しますとこの40年間の予約の親父は目覚ましいものがありましてその進歩
の恩恵をですね
私も患者さんとともに
享受してきたからであります
ここではホスピス緩和ケアの現場において
いやスケア行うスタッフがですね実は癒されているということを
お話さらに私たちが
直面している
超高齢化社会をどのように生き抜くかということについても一つの提案をしたいと思い
ます
じゃどれぐらい生きるかということです
このグラフは
彼のには大学から報告されたものでありますが
2007年前の子供の半数が到達する年齢を
医学の進歩を考え見て推測したものであります
日本を含むアメリカフランスイギリスなどですね
すべての先進国の今小学校3年生
実際のこのさんが盗撮する年齢はなんと100歳を超えています
う日本人はグリーンで示しますがなんと107歳という驚くべきデータですね
つまり近い将来私たちは100歳人生を歩むわけです
じゃあこの100歳になってどのように元気で活動しているかということが私たち両者
の今
研究課題であります私たちは
さるくぴにゃフレールって一つの問題はですね
取り組んでいるところですが
これは次回の次の機会にお話したいと思います
えっこの100歳人生っていうのはですね
私は日々の臨床の中で感じていますそれはこの10年間特に
進歩しているのでありますが
高血圧とか糖尿病とか高脂血症の
いわゆる生活習慣病ですねこれが非常に良好にコントロールされるようになりまして
もう出血は激減して糖尿病による腎不全の
血液透析の患者さんも年々減少しています
さらに多くの患者さんが亡くなったがんですね
これについても同様で
ここに示します宦官は市が高いウイルスの排除によってまた胃がんはですね
ヘリコバクターピロリ菌の
除菌治療によって将来激減すると予防できるというふうに思います
さらに若い患者さんが苦しんできた
関節リュウマチクローン病潰瘍性大腸炎という難病もですね
tnf 両方の登場によりまして学業に専念できるし
仕事にも従事できるという時代であります
さらに
再生医療の発達や
認知アルツハイマー認知症の予防薬の登場によって私たちは
人生100年どころか110年120年という風に
生きる時代が来ると予想されています
この中で私が取り組んできた
c 型肝炎ウイルスの診療についてご紹介したいと思います
し型肝炎ウィルスの発見は今から29年前の1988年に見つけられましてそれで去年
を通しですね
2015年には
蛍光剤飲み薬によってほとんどすべての患者さんの c 型肝炎が排除されるという
画期的な
あ
診療の珍宝がありましたそれに触発されて私はこの27年間の当院でのし型肝炎の診療
について
紙カルテと電子カルテを用いて調べました
まず治療成績であります
し型肝炎が発見されて4年後ですね
インターフェロンの治療始めました
すごく負担がかかる経済的にもですね
肉体的もかかる治療でしたけど残念ながら
2014年まで
68パーセントしか生えずできなかった
しかし2014年には100%になり2015年にはですねインターフェロンを抜きの
蛍光剤でほとんどの方が治るという風な成績です
一方この27年間の亡くなった患者さんについても
検索いたしました
2066名の患者さんが当院でなくなっています
そのうち約10%209の方がですね
肝臓病疾患でなくなっておられます
そしてそのうちの64%が c 型肝炎ウイルスによる肝がんでなくなっています
この子型肝炎の患者さんを診療することによって
私は
ホスピス緩和ケアに必要な技術とホスピス mind
学んできましたその一つは
患者さんや家族に寄り添い支える医療ということそれから2つ目は十分が説明をして
ですね
患者さんが自己決定をすることを援助するということ
3つ目は玩具ために代表される
苦しい辛い症状を速やかに除去するということであります
そういうことで
徳島では始めたのですね
ホスピス徳島を2002年に立ち上げることができました
これは
2000年から活動していたいただいている
ボランティアの皆さんでこの中にし型肝炎で亡くされたご家族はですねご家族の方が数
名
おいでになります
これは2002年に新築した本のない花弁の夜景です
3階がホスピス徳島です
ホスピスの歴史について少し触れたいと思います
ホスピスケアは
ヨーロッパの中世に思いに修道院で行われてきました
今から50年前1940
1967年ですねロンドンに近来ホスピスが誕生しました
セントクリストファーホスピスですそのそうしたが
国には売られる獅子自尊弾先生であります
私はこのホスピスケアっていうのを2000兄10年ほど前に知りましたその一つの柱
はですね
これで of life って買いなんです
二つ目は
チーム医療1人の患者さんを多職種のスタッフが支える
3つ目が癌の疼痛に対する徹底した医療用麻薬の資料でした
この
ホスピスケアを知ってですね
私たちが行ってきた進路鳥栖
よく似ているなというふうに感じましたけれども
理論的な裏付けが非常に良くてですね診療の質を
深めることができました
おすす徳島における14年間の患者胴体ですが去年の3月までに
1,700名余りの患者さんを見となの感想を看取っています
私たちが主催する徳島元リハビリテーションネットワークの
楽委員会でですねある威力館の
看護部の責任者の方から当院のたいな看護部長の質問がありました
こんなに沢山の
がんの患者さんを見とってて
スター看護師の皆さんの心のケアどな音してるんですかってことですね
そういうことでん
看護部長が
アンケート方式を用いてスターディを行いました
彼はケアに勤務する22名の看護師を対象に
緩和型病棟ホスピス徳島で行なっている癒しの活動実行木
季節の領事とか3月の3ヶ月の手紙とか
たんじょうかい
それから切れ味の会話とかですねそういう項目を挙げてアンケートいたしました
そういうケアをすることで自分が癒されていると思うかということですね
で大変思うと
よく思いますっていうのがそこのグラフに出ていることです
ご覧のようにもずいぶんたくさんの
元看護師の方がですね
ヤサズルッということがわかります
つまりホスピス緩和ケアの現場においてはですね
ケアするものが
癒しのケアを行う行うものが癒し
そして癒されるということであります
印象に残った
患者さんをご紹介します
32歳の子宮頸がん末期の女性がニューしてまいりました
担当している看護師は
いろいろ話を聞いたときに
結婚し直後にですね発病して闘病生活で結婚式を挙げていない
いうことを聞きまして私たちがじゃあ準備して
やりましょうかという提案をしました
で
その結果ですねスタッフ全員が
結婚式の企画運営を行いました
私はお二人がクリスチャンだったものですから
牧師の薬を押す疲れました
素晴らしい結婚式でした
新郎新婦はもとよりご家族や新
親族友人の方も大変喜ばれてですね
で私たちスタッフも
癒されたわけであります
梅雨はな特徴のあるほど良いです
ほんま音が毎年お盆にを取りにきてくれます
緩和ケア病棟を開設2年前のお盆にですね
連長の奥さんが私に言いました
ですを分に主人が私の側には結婚したから初めてです
と言われてお盆の民家目にですね
がんで亡くなられました
その後に
ホスピスをするのでを取りにきてくれませんかと依頼して毎年来ていただいております
これは5月の端午の節句に
ホスピスガーデンに登っている
こいのぼりですこのこいのぼりをさんがへの
棺桶アロン時から眺めて
膨らんでまた跳ね返るこいのぼりと
一句詠んだ患者さんがいます
91歳の
形で
嫁1カ月と言われて庭園してまいりました
しかし
ホスピス徳島での生活が非常に楽しまれてですね
なんと6ヵ月生き抜きました
そういう分かったことは俳句の先生でもあるしお茶の先生でもあるし
また日本側ですね
京都のお寺がから襖絵を依頼される多芸な方でした
毎日あの娘さんが完了に来られるんですがどんなに具合悪くても9時が来たら買いなさ
いって言って返してた最後の日はですね
さすがに主任看護師が
今日も止まりなさいと言って止まったんですね
私は麻の葉7人
あいさつに出かけました
皆さんはあ
赤い蝶ネクタイにマッシュのブレザーを着てですね
穏やかのからでした
娘さんから
先生
雄弁父と
は彼の乾杯をしましたっていうアレですねお互いにありがとうって言ってお別れしたと
いうことでした
何の酒で乾杯したんですかっていうと
表明して
乾杯しました言われて私は思わず
微笑みました
非常に噂れた患者さんです
私はずいぶんたくさんの間亡くなられているかと思いました見てきまして
歯についてはですね
悲しいことではあるけれど
残された家族親族にとっては
次の一歩を踏み出す大きな出来事ではないかなというふうに感じています
9年ですね時の大学に留学していた
エジプトからのあしらう先生とマレーシアからのマリア先生と
と訪問看護師て4人で
こある日よりの午後に徳島しようとしのしないの
自宅で療養している患者さんの帽子に出かけました
たまたま89歳の
もう血管障害で養生していたアンさんが亡くなられて4人でオタク訪れました
穏やかな口語しようかをです
それで私は2人の先生に
徳島の方は皆こんな風に
穏やかな顔で
なくなるんだけど
あなたたちの国ではと尋ねますと
マリア先生がすかさず
私たちのクリーム同じです
これは英語と peaceful フェイスと言いますと答えたんですね
私はこのピースレースということが非常に大切で
人中機に
親族の方がなるべく多く集まるようにおすすめしています
つまり
歯が命の
バトンタッチになるようにということが彼は蹴る音の大きな目標の一つです
は徳島市のシンボルの眉山です
肺がんねはい金 new していた
ローカメラばに絡んいただいたベストショットです
今までお話してきたように
ホスピス緩和ケア
がですね
人間本来持っているであろう
癒し癒されるっていう
関係性を醸し出してくると
いうことが分かりました
今後超高齢化社会を迎える私たちに必要なのは病院
それから海軍施設
さらには地域社会においてですね
ホスピス緩和ケアが浸透することが重要と考えています
そうすればわたしたちの住む徳島も
豊かな社会になるという風に
信じて今後も活動してもらいますご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]
[音楽]
tan